reclus dans leur tranchées ces soldats
Ukrainiens préparent leur prochain tirs
de mortier en face à quelques kilomètres
l'infanterie russe avance vers backmouth
pour les contenir ils tirent près de 200
obus par jour
est un endroit difficile c'est un
territoire difficile à défendre beaucoup
de batailles doivent être menées
il y a une très grande concentration
d'infanterie et demi comme ils veulent
prendre la ville à tout prix il lance
toute leur force ici le groupe
paramilitaire Wagner en première ligne
dans la bataille de bakkmouth tente
d'encercler la défense ukrainienne il
revendique ces dernières semaines la
prise de plusieurs localités autour de
la ville résultat à trois des quatre
routes qui permettaient aux Ukrainiens
d'approvisionner backmouth sont
désormais tenus par les Russes
les forces armées ukrainiennes lancent
des unités supplémentaires à barmouth et
tente de tenir la ville de toutes leurs
forces
des dizaines de milliers de soldats de
l'armée ukrainienne offre une résistance
sérieuse
fusion de sang augmente chaque jour
dans le village de châssivia sur la
route ouest la seule encore contrôlée
par les Ukrainiens des soldats viennent
chercher les derniers civils à évacuer
bonjour y a-t-il autre chose à prendre
en sac c'est tout cette famille n'a
d'autre choix que de s'éloigner des
combats
ce qu'il y a des tirs c'était notre
septième lieu de résidence
où les autres
la prise de bachmouth ouvrirait aux
forces russes la voie vers le reste du
Dombas et notamment la ville de
kramatorzk à 50 km au nord-ouest
et